x-rays
they wrap my arm poorly
put this brace on my leg and they're
like you need like two major surgeries
and i was like not here
yeah yeah and they're like you want to
go home and i was like [ __ ] yes can i
guess what hospital
no because i can't say i know but we'll
bleep it was it in the valley no okay
god because there's one there where i'm
like nobody go there everyone dies
there's one really good one in the
valley was it was it in like you know
more inner city no
but why are we playing this game
though i got picked up i got picked up i
can't walk move anything i mean
everything's fresh broken oh my god and
i get in my friend's car and what we
should have done
is gone right to the emergency room of
another hospital yeah i went home
oh no
i went home completely
broken
i got help
to get to a couch
and then i was like
all right like just uh
in the morning i guess we'll figure this
out
and so in the morning like bert and my
friend lindsey we
they get me into a van and i go to a
doctor right and there's a doctor
through a concert like through a like a
doctor friend was like you need to go
see
this dude this dude's the [ __ ] he's a
sports
uh trauma guy
so i get in there
he goes what the [ __ ] are you doing here
man
wow wow i was like what do you mean he
was like go to the hospital
i was like
all right i was at a hospital last night
he goes you left and i was like i was at
that hospital yeah and he was like oh
yeah i would have left her yeah yeah
yeah he's like but you shouldn't be here
you should be at a hospital how did you
spend the night in your house in all
that pain were you just in like a fever
dream like yeah i was like i wasn't even
like falling asleep you know it was just
like kind of
i probably slept i don't know an hour or
two i just i'm so curious to know what
christina is like what she was saying
she was i think she was kind of
overwhelmed
because like the christians came and
like
set stuff up in this room and you know
[ __ ] burt even like he knew how
[ __ ] up i was yeah next to the
nightstand he put a a jar of vitamin c
and uh and calcium for your bones
[Laughter]
and uh and then snacks
he put all types of stuff like doritos
the [ __ ] is all this yeah yeah in case
you get hungry like yeah cheetos and she
knows i'm not eating this [ __ ] man i'm
like wow and then yeah so then then it
was a whole you know thing after that
but
yeah it was wild
well i'm glad you're alive yeah me too
man oh that's this is what prompted it
that doctor
when i when he when i wheeled into his
office he was like what are you doing
here you know he was like all right let
me tell you what's gonna happen he goes
he's like this isn't [ __ ] he points to
my arm he's like
that just they're just gonna
put some plates in there and your arm's
gonna he goes this is a [ __ ] problem
right and i go okay he goes like you
gotta reattach a tendon to your patella
and your knee is not gonna work for it's
gonna be a long thing and i go okay
and he goes but look at the upside could
have been worse and i go how so
and he goes you know how you fell back
and i go yeah he goes you could have
landed on your head and then you'd slur
for the rest of your life he just stared
at me and i was like oh [ __ ] okay oh my
gosh because he's right you know like if
i had landed on my head instead of my
arm yeah you know you could have had
brain damage yeah you know there i knew
this kid in high school um and he was a
star baseball player and he had some
weird freak accident with a skateboard
it wasn't like he was bombing a hill or
anything it was just like he was trying
to do like a basic ollie
and he just fell wrong and he landed on
the back of his head here and to this
day he um is not just he's a
quadriplegic
like he is unable to care for himself
like when i hear [ __ ] like that i get so
freaked out by freak accidents like that
yeah i mean if you had if you landed on
your head and you had a slur right
how long
do would we have to wait to make fun of
you well people would have right away no
i wouldn't have i would have waited at
least six months six months and they had
you on and got high
and then just mocked you you know i'm
[ __ ] thai or something like
so
yeah people would admit i mean you know
we're comics we would have yeah i don't
think i i don't i don't know you see i
don't think i would
i'd feel so devastated it would be i
think it would be devastating the people
close to me would be [ __ ] up because
you guys would all be like
that could be you'd be like oh yeah that
could be us you know like people who and
i'm sitting here being like
how's everybody doing tonight oh
my god and then i have to convince you
after shows like no that was it was
really good oh yeah right and i just get
like
i get a bunch of like pity
kitty and then you all your jokes would
have to be kind of revolved around the
slur
oh yeah i mean oh of course yeah yeah
yeah yeah it would be like an hour of
like
yeah i just everybody talks differently
that's a good one well it would just be
like a new
like madonna it's just a new look a new
look yeah yeah the slur guy though
oh my god i get i'd get invited to like
those like speech impediment seminars
like you guys can be successful
like i'm on netflix
i know yeah and then we would have to
like come over a lot
you think we'd have to come over a lot
especially in the beginning i'm sure
he'd hate it he'd be like please like
come and like you know get like a speech
therapy machine do they have those yeah
speech therapy
i don't know something you know i would
get it on ebay or whatever yeah and
bring it over maybe this will help
you know what i mean you put it on your
face i don't know how it works i mean i
i knew a guy who was
[Laughter]
i knew a hot guy who was struck by
lightning and he needed to um
he was very still very highly [ __ ]
but he did have a weird lightning voice
i can't say his name but this is really
his name but i remember my friend and i
were like oh my god that's got that
guy's so hot we went over i was like hey
you know like my name's so-and-so and
he's like my name is
[Laughter]
but he's still hot really he's still hot
mm-hmm black guy
half asian guy and um my friend still
made out with him didn't care all right
yeah wait did you where you just saw him
like sitting around somewhere he was at
a party we were younger it was like a
friend's like house party and so you're
like you knew he was already hit by
lightning no we didn't oh so you're just
this guy's hot let's go talk and then
later on
[Music]
like he's talking he had to put a
machine to his throat like yeah like
it's kind of like to uh magnify the
voice oh i said he was like but you know
um
yeah he was just yeah but when you're in
bed you know it doesn't matter right
yeah yeah it really does
it's good he's gonna make fun you know
what he puts the mic to it i'm going to
come yeah yeah oh yeah feels good
but imagine that
imagine if you had sex with him and then
he he uh he doesn't pull out and you're
like did you come inside me he's like
sorry about that
dude you got to [ __ ] tell me
[Laughter]
right yeah he couldn't stop because yeah
he's like i don't want him to go grab
the machine production right stop having
sex where do you want me to come
here
or he just he would just say i'm gonna
do it and she says no you're right i
don't care
i'll forget it
cut that part
you cannot cut that out
i'm blushing because the joke didn't
work that thank you
[Laughter]
unhelpful advice i'm sorry you know what
i wish i would have known more i would
have got you gifts or whatever i just
didn't know much it's totally okay that
was a car accident but go uh go ahead
a loaf of advice with time security oh
so embarrassing hello this week's
unhelpful advice is brought to you by
the big papayas over at patreon